dos contenedores de basura en llamas en
las calles de beirut aquel 17 de octubre
los libaneses protestan en contra de un
impuesto por el uso de la aplicación de
mensajería de whatsapp ellos no lo
sabían pero en las horas siguientes
millones de compatriotas se unirían a
ellos al día siguiente los manifestantes
comenzaron a gritar revolución y las
protestas se extienden en todo el país
en frente del palacio del primer
ministro se levanta el eslogan de las
revoluciones árabes
que todos salgan todos del más
importante al menos importante ellos nos
robaron a tres días después ya son medio
millón de personas por primera vez en la
historia del país los libaneses de todas
las religiones marcharon juntos en
contra de sus dirigentes y reclaman un
cambio de régimen tras la renuncia de
hariri y reemplazado por un casi
desconocido
hasan diab las calles están llenas de
manifestantes los miembros de su
gobierno presentados como independientes
son en realidad elegidos por las fuerzas
políticas tradicionales
el fin de semana del 18 de enero cerca
de 550 personas resultaron heridos
bajo el mandato de hasan diab la
economía se desploma la moneda nacional
pierde el 100% de su valor y el gobierno
no alcanza un acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional muchos libaneses
no manifestaron más
el 4 de agosto se dio lo impensable dos
mil setecientos cincuenta toneladas de
nitrato de amonio descuidadas por las
autoridades explotan en el puerto de
beirut la catástrofe dejó más de 200
muertos y 6.500 heridos
la explosión revive la respuesta social
y causó la renuncia del primer ministro
hasan diab
luego de dos visitas al líbano en menos
de un mes el presidente francés emmanuel
mccomb presionó a los dirigentes a
formar un nuevo gobierno sin éxito un
año después del inicio de la revolución
algunos contestatarios intentan mantener
viva la llama del movimiento que amenaza
con extinguirse la clase política de
siempre todavía está en el poder